When Amy and her dad were loading her mom into the car, Amy didn't think this would be the very last time her mom would go to the hospital. But her dad did. In fact, he called a priest, a priest who Amy's mom, Janet, was friends with, to hear her mom's confession and administer last rights, just in case. Her mom had been diagnosed with cancer two years before, and Amy says it was clear she didn't have much time left.
当艾米和她爸爸把她妈妈扶上车时，艾米并没有想到这将是她妈妈最后一次去医院。但她爸爸想到了。事实上，他叫了一位牧师——一位艾米的妈妈珍妮特的朋友，来听她妈妈的忏悔并进行临终圣事，以防万一。她妈妈两年前被诊断出患有癌症，艾米说很明显她剩下的时间不多了。
So we got in the car, and I set the GPS for Weill Cornell, and we got on to the Long Island Expressway, and--
于是我们上了车，我设置了前往威尔康奈尔医院的导航，我们上了长岛高速公路，然后——
Amy had driven this trip dozens and dozens of times over two years of treatment-- to Weill Cornell Hospital in New York City from out in Long Island. It was a straight shot up the expressway. Amy knows the way by heart, but she always uses the Waze app, because it reroutes when the traffic's bad.
在两年的治疗过程中，艾米已经无数次开车走过这条路——从长岛到纽约市的威尔康奈尔医院。这是一条直通高速公路的路线。艾米对这条路了如指掌，但她总是使用Waze应用程序，因为它会在交通拥堵时重新规划路线。
And I've become, like, such a slave to the GPS, I just follow it like I'm a robot. And I'm following it, and at one point, my dad's in the backseat. My mom's sitting next to me in the front seat.
我已经变得像GPS的奴隶一样了，我像机器人一样跟着它走。我跟着它走，有一次，我爸爸坐在后座，我妈妈坐在我旁边的副驾驶座上。
And at one point, my dad said, like, where are you going? Like, why are you going this way? And I don't even know exactly where I was. I think it had taken me to the Cross Island, and then an exit in Queens.
有一次，我爸爸说，你这是要去哪儿？为什么你要走这条路？我甚至不知道自己到底在哪里。我想它把我带到了跨岛高速公路，然后在皇后区的一个出口下来了。
And he was like, why are you going this way? And I was like, the GPS says-- I'm just following the GPS-- (LAUGHING) like I always do. And then it told me to make a left on Broadway in Queens.
他问，你为什么要走这条路？我说，GPS说的——我只是跟着GPS走——（笑）像我平时做的那样。然后它告诉我在皇后区的百老汇大街左转。
I made the left, and dad was like, oh my god, Janet, we're going to go right by-- Janet, do you know where we are?
我左转了，爸爸说，天哪，珍妮特，我们正要经过——珍妮特，你知道我们在哪里吗？
It had taken them right to the neighborhood where her parents were first a couple, working together in his family's business. The GPS told them to make a turn.
它把他们带到了他们父母最初相爱、在家族企业一起工作的那个街区。GPS让他们转弯。
On that corner is a bakery. It's an old Italian bakery. It's been there. And I think I have the name of it somewhere. Yeah, it's called Parisi's Bakery. And it's right on the corner there. It's been there forever.
那个街角有一家面包店。那是一家老式意大利面包店。它一直在那儿。我想我某个地方有它的名字。对了，它叫帕里西面包店。它就在那个街角。它一直在那儿。
And my parents used to always pick up their bread for their big Italian meals with my grandmother. She would be like, get the bread at Parisi's. Go to Parisi's. Get the bread.
我父母过去常常去那儿买面包，和我的祖母一起享用他们的意大利大餐。她会说，去帕里西买面包。去帕里西。把面包买回来。
Wait, when they were how old?
等等，他们那时候多大？
When they were, you know, teenagers. Like, when they were, like, 19 and 20, and they were working in Queens. And my dad was freaking out about the bakery, and so I pulled over, and I said, Dad, why don't you get a loaf of bread? And he jumped out of the car, and he went and got a loaf of bread and some cookies for my mother.
他们那时候，你知道，还是青少年。大概19岁和20岁的时候，他们在皇后区工作。我爸爸对这家面包店感到非常兴奋，所以我靠边停车，我说，爸爸，你为什么不去买一条面包呢？他跳下车，去给我妈妈买了一条面包和一些饼干。
Amy drives on, and the GPS next routes them right past this diner, the Bel Aire Diner.
艾米继续开车，GPS接下来引导他们直接经过这家餐馆，贝尔艾尔餐厅。
--that they had breakfast at every morning when they were in their 20s. Before they would go to the factory, they would go with my grandfather, sometimes with my uncle, too. And they would sit at the counter, and they would have, like, a doughnut and coffee, or, like--
——那是他们20多岁时每天早上吃早餐的地方。在去工厂之前，他们会和我祖父一起去，有时也和我叔叔一起去。他们会坐在吧台边，吃个甜甜圈喝杯咖啡，或者，类似这样——
And my dad was pointing at everything, like, and this is where-- and Janet, do you remember? We used to go here, and look, I can't believe this is where we are right now. This is crazy.
我爸爸指着所有东西说，这里是——珍妮特，你还记得吗？我们以前常来这里，你看，我不敢相信我们现在就在这里。这太疯狂了。
And there was a restaurant around the corner that's no longer there, that is where my father had proposed to my mom. It was weird. Their little-- that was the world of their beginning. Those were the blocks they spent the most time on when they were starting out, you know. It was very strange to just end up right there.
拐角处有一家餐馆现在已经不在了，那是我父亲向我母亲求婚的地方。这很奇怪。他们的小天地——那是他们开始的世界。那是他们刚开始在一起时花最多时间的地方，你知道。就这么出现在那里真的很奇怪。
And how many times had you driven them from their house to this hospital?
你带他们从家去这家医院多少次了？
Oh, my god. Oh, my god. I mean, Oh, god, it's not a number I can even count.
哦，天哪。哦，天哪。我是说，天哪，这不是一个我能数得清的数字。
How many times had it sent you this way?
它有多少次带你走这条路？
Never, never. No, we never went that way.
从来没有，从来没有。不，我们从没走过那条路。
Did you say much? Or was it really, like, between the two of them for most of it?
你说了什么吗？还是大部分时间都是他们两个人的世界？
No, he was-- it was really him. It was really Dad just being like, Janet, look at this. Oh my god, do you remember when we used to walk down this way every night after work?
不，他——真的是他。真的是爸爸一直在说，珍妮特，看这个。天哪，你还记得我们以前每天下班后沿着这条路走吗？
It was like he was like a kid. He was really excited. He was really excited to be there, like visiting a museum of your childhood or something, you know.
他就像个孩子一样。他真的很兴奋。他真的很高兴能到那里，就像参观你的童年博物馆之类的，你知道。
Yeah, well, it's like that cliche almost, like that when you're dying, your whole life will flash before your eyes, except you guys were actually, like, doing it on location for real, thanks to the GPS.
是的，这几乎成了陈词滥调，就像人们常说当你快要死的时候，你的一生会像电影一样在你眼前闪过，只不过你们在GPS的帮助下，实际上是在实地重温这一切。
(LAUGHING) Yeah, exactly. Waze really had it planned for us. [CHUCKLES]
（笑）是的，正是这样。Waze确实为我们做了安排。（轻笑）
Amy says once they got to Queens, she suddenly found herself in this moment that was really about the two of them as a couple, the couple they were before she was born. Her parents got together when they were 16. And she says the older she's gotten, the better she's understood how well suited her parents were for each other, in all kinds of ways.
艾米说，一旦他们到了皇后区，她突然发现自己置身于这属于他们夫妻的时刻，属于她出生之前他们的时刻。她父母16岁时就在一起了。她说，她年纪越大，就越能理解父母在各方面是多么地契合。
Growing up, she says, every night, they would pull out a guitar after dinner and sing together, the two of them, harmonize on Beatles or Bob Dylan songs just for themselves, because they liked it. Amy says she didn't realize how unusual it was for parents to do till she got older. This is a home recording of them from just a few years ago.
她说，在成长过程中，每天晚餐后他们都会拿出吉他一起唱歌，他们俩，为他们自己和声演唱披头士或鲍勃·迪伦的歌，因为他们喜欢。艾米说，直到长大后她才意识到父母这样做是多么不同寻常。这是他们几年前的家庭录音。
[MUSIC - "I'LL FOLLOW THE SUN" BY THE BEATLES]
[音乐 - 披头士的“I'LL FOLLOW THE SUN”]
And now, the time has come, and so my love, I must go. And though I lose a friend, in the end you will know. Oh, oh.
现在，时间到了，所以我的爱人，我必须离开。虽然我失去了一个朋友，但最终你会明白。哦，哦。
Amy's mom, Janet, died a week after that ride to the hospital. But in the car that day in Queens, her mom looked around at the stuff her dad was pointing to, and she was in it with him, smiled and said, yes, when he asked, did she see? Meanwhile at the wheel was Amy, the driver.
艾米的妈妈珍妮特在去医院的那次车程一周后去世了。但在皇后区车里的那天，她妈妈看着她爸爸指着的东西，她和他一起沉浸其中，微笑着说，是的，当他问她看到了吗。与此同时，坐在驾驶座上的是艾米，那个司机。
I'm trying to keep both their spirits up, like a maniac, you know. So I'm basically, like, reflecting my father's enthusiasm, and you know, I'm the one that pulled over in front of the bakery and said, just jump out and get a loaf of bread. You know, it's fine. We're OK.
我像个疯子一样试图让他们俩都保持精神，你知道。所以我基本上是在回应我父亲的热情，而且你知道，是我把车停在面包店前说，跳下车去买条面包吧。你知道，没事的。我们很好。
Like, we weren't-- she was not in pain, and we were there, and it was going to take as long as it was going to take. And you know, we're Italian, and bread makes us feel better. So get some bread.
就像，我们没有——她当时并不痛苦，我们在那里，事情顺其自然就好。而且你知道，我们是意大利人，面包让我们感觉更好。所以去买些面包吧。
It's This American Life, by the way. I'm Ira Glass. Today's episode, we're calling "The Ferryman." It's about people who transport other people to some destination. And in preparing for the show today, a bunch of us were looking at the old Greek myth of the ferryman, you know, whose boat carries souls across the river to the afterlife.
顺便说一句，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天这期节目我们叫“摆渡人”。它是关于运送他人前往某个目的地的人。在准备今天节目的时候，我们很多人研究了关于摆渡人的古希腊神话，你知道，他的船运送灵魂跨越河流前往来世。
His name is Charon, and he's just, like, awful. It's this frightening figure, the way that Virgil and Dante write about him-- just unruly, white beard, terrifying eyes. Doesn't seem to talk hardly ever, but when he does, it's pretty aggro, ordering people around. Kind of, exactly who you would not want to be ferried by in a frightening moment.
他的名字叫卡戎，他简直糟透了。维吉尔和但丁笔下的他是一个可怕的人物——桀骜不驯，白胡子，可怕的眼睛。他几乎不说话，但一旦开口，就非常具有攻击性，对人发号施令。有点像你在可怕时刻最不想被其摆渡的人。
Who you'd want, of course, is someone like your own kid, somebody who's actually worried about you, wants to make it as OK as possible. Today on our program, we have a bunch of stories of people going from one place to another who need safe passage.
当然，你想要的是像你自己的孩子那样的人，一个真正担心你、想让你尽可能感到安心的人。今天我们的节目里，有一群从一个地方去往另一个地方、需要安全通行的人的故事。
And if you picture, like, a long lineup, like a continuum of ferrymen, where at one end is Amy, who's trying to be kind, and at the other end is the immortal ferryman, Charon, who is definitely not, all the ferrymen in today's episode fall at different paths between the two on that lineup. We hear about who they are and what gets them through their jobs, where they see so much along the way. Stay with us.
如果你想象一下，像一个长长的摆渡人队列，一端是试图善良的艾米，另一端是绝对不善良的不朽摆渡人卡戎，今天节目里的所有摆渡人都落在这个队列的不同位置。我们将听到他们是谁，以及是什么支撑他们完成这份工作，还有他们在沿途看到了什么。请继续关注。
Act One, I Was a Teenage Smuggler. So the first story is about a very particular version of the job of getting people from point A to point B. You've probably heard of all the people trying to illegally cross the Mexican border into the United States recently. It's the most in two decades.
第一幕，我是少年走私犯。所以第一个故事是关于从A点到B点运送人这份工作的特殊版本。你可能听说过最近有很多人试图非法越过墨西哥边境进入美国。这是二十年来最多的一次。
Here's what you might not know. I didn't know this. Many of the guides ferrying them across the US-Mexican border are kids. This is mostly because of us, because of the United States.
这是你可能不知道的。我以前也不知道。许多在美墨边境摆渡的向导都是孩子。这主要是因为我们，因为美国。
The US government, as a general matter, does not prosecute smugglers who are under 18. So those kids can lead migrants into the country, get caught, and they don't get charged with smuggling or illegally crossing into the United States. They're just sent right back to Mexico.
美国政府一般不会起诉18岁以下的走私者。所以那些孩子可以带领移民入境，被抓到后，他们不会被指控走私或非法入境美国。他们只是被直接送回墨西哥。
Needless to say, this makes them very attractive for the cartels, who run these big operations crossing migrants. Some kids get coerced into doing the job or into staying at the job. And it can be dangerous getting so close to the cartels.
不用说，这使他们成为贩毒集团非常有吸引力的对象，这些集团经营着大规模的跨越移民业务。一些孩子被胁迫从事这项工作或留在这个岗位上。而且离贩毒集团那么近是很危险的。
But for lots of kids, it's just a job. It's just money, good money. Kevin Sieff, a reporter for The Washington Post, spent months with a bunch of these kid smugglers, and got to know them, talked to them about what it was like to do this particular kind of ferrymen's job. Here's Kevin.
但对许多孩子来说，这只是一份工作。这只是钱，赚快钱。《华盛顿邮报》的记者凯文·西夫花了几个月时间和这些少年走私犯在一起，了解了他们，并与他们谈论从事这种特殊的摆渡人工作是什么感觉。请听凯文的讲述。
In parts of northern Mexico, human smuggling almost feels like Little League. The kids boast about who's better-- faster up the border wall, more skilled at hiding from the border patrol. They post on Snapchat about the migrants they cross.
在墨西哥北部的一些地方，人口走私几乎感觉就像少棒联盟。孩子们吹嘘谁更厉害——翻越边境墙更快，躲避边境巡逻更专业。他们在Snapchat上发布他们运送的移民的照片。
On Facebook, one kid I know changed his profession to "smuggler." That's how this other kid, Israel, learned that this was even a job-- on Facebook.
在Facebook上，我认识的一个孩子把他的职业改成了“走私犯”。这就是那个孩子，以色列，在Facebook上得知这甚至是一份工作。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
He was 15, with chubby cheeks and a wispy mustache. He liked posting pictures of cute miniature horses. One day, he was at his grandma's house, and some clips another boy had posted of his exploits popped up on his feed.
他15岁，脸颊圆嘟嘟，留着稀疏的胡子。他喜欢发可爱迷你马的照片。有一天，他在他奶奶家，另一个男孩发布的他自己功绩的片段出现在他的信息流里。
And what did you think when you watched these videos?
当你观看这些视频时，你怎么想？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
That I wanted to do it, too. I saw he was getting a lot of money, and I said, I want to do it, too.
我也想做。我看到他赚了很多钱，我说，我也想做。
He messaged the guy out of boredom and curiosity. Can you take me along? The guy said, sure. Meet me in my house. And so Israel got dressed the same way he did for school-- jeans, cross trainers. What are smugglers supposed to wear anyway, he thought.
他出于无聊和好奇给那个人发了信息。你能带我一起去吗？那人说，没问题。到我家见我。于是以色列穿上了和去学校一样的衣服——牛仔裤，运动鞋。他想，反正走私犯该穿什么呢？
And he headed out. Again, he was 15. They picked up a handful of migrants who were hiding in a house nearby, and took them to the Rio Grande. It was night when they waded into the river.
然后他出发了。再一次，他15岁。他们接了一小群躲在附近房子里的移民，带他们去了格兰德河。他们涉水进入河里时是晚上。
The migrants followed behind them in inner tubes. Israel helped lead them, pretending he knew what he was doing.
移民们在他们身后用内胎跟随着。以色列帮忙引导他们，假装他知道自己在做什么。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I thought, what am I doing? But I was already there, and I thought, OK, let's just continue forward.
我心想，我在做什么？但我已经在那里了，我想，好吧，继续前进吧。
Once they got to the other side, it was a quick climb over the border wall, about four minutes. The other smuggler told Israel the technique-- sort of, like climbing a tree, just a little harder. They helped the migrants get over, one by one. Israel remembers being like, wait, that's it? We did it?
一旦他们到达对岸，翻过边境墙只需要很短的时间，大约四分钟。另一个走私犯告诉以色列技巧——有点像爬树，只是难一点点。他们帮移民一个接一个地翻过去。以色列记得当时想的是，等等，就这？我们做到了？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
It felt great. It was easy. I mean, there were no complications at all. There was not even immigration. I thought, this isn't even hard.
感觉太棒了。这很简单。我的意思是，根本没有任何复杂情况。甚至没有移民局。我想，这甚至都不难。
The people they had crossed looked up at him, this little kid, like he was a boss. The next morning, Israel, 15 years old, walked across the international bridge to get home, like he was just another tourist returning from shopping in Texas. When he got back to Mexico, the cartel paid him a wad of cash for helping out. The normal rate is about $100 per migrant.
他们带过境的人抬头看着他，这个小孩，仿佛他是老板。第二天早上，15岁的以色列走过国际大桥回家，就像他只是另一个刚从得克萨斯州购物回来的游客。当他回到墨西哥时，贩毒集团给了他一叠现金作为酬劳。通常的价格是每名移民约100美元。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
When I was a little kid, I used to wash cars. I made what a worker makes in two weeks-- I made it in one night. You feel like money is never going to run out, that you're always going to have money, always, always.
当我还是个小孩子的时候，我过去常常洗车。我赚到了一个工人在两周内赚的钱——我一个晚上就赚到了。你觉得钱永远花不完，你会一直一直有钱。
Once he started doing this more regularly, he'd post pictures of the money he got on Facebook, with emojis of a smiley face with dollar signs for the eyes. This is the engine behind one of the world's largest human migrations. People are handed from smuggler to smuggler, like links in a chain, until they get to the border.
一旦他开始更频繁地这样做，他就会在Facebook上发布他得到的钱的照片，配上眼睛里有美元符号的笑脸表情符号。这就是全球最大的人口迁移背后的引擎。人们像链条上的环节一样被从一个走私犯交到另一个走私犯手中，直到他们到达边境。
And when they get there, the last guides who take them on the last mile of the journey are teenage boys doing teenage boy things. Like, there are these two brothers, Jassiel and Alfonso. They're like the class clowns of the smuggling world. Here's Alfonso.
当他们到达那里时，带领他们走最后一段旅程的最后向导是做着青春期男孩该做的事的少年男孩。比如，有两兄弟，贾西尔和阿方索。他们就像走私界的捣蛋鬼。这是阿方索。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
The funniest, well, is my brother, because he's, kind of, crazy. He does things that you shouldn't-- you shouldn't really do at the border patrol. He'll get naked and start running.
最搞笑的，嗯，是我哥哥，因为他有点疯狂。他做了一些你不该做的事——你不应该真的在边境巡逻队面前做的事。他会脱光衣服开始奔跑。
Like this one time, Jassiel had crossed the river with a group of migrants. Border patrol agents showed up, and he started to run. He knows he can beat them, no problem.
就像有一次，贾西尔带着一群移民过了河。边境巡逻特工出现了，他开始跑。他知道他能甩掉他们，没问题。
I already have-- I already have, like, a record for running. They're older. They already have, like, wrinkles.
我已经——我已经有跑步的记录了。他们年纪大了。他们已经有皱纹了。
He got back to the riverbank, with them still in pursuit. One of the agents shouted at him. He said the patrol boats were coming. The agent was like, you're stuck. There's no way to escape.
他回到河岸，特工还在后面追赶。其中一名特工对他大喊。他说巡逻船要来了。特工说，你被困住了。没法逃跑了。
And I said to him, I said, no way. There's always a way out. He told me that, you think you're so-- and I told him, no, well, it's just too bad. I'm not going to let myself get caught. I said, you do your job, and I'll do mine, and we'll go home happy.
我对他说，我说，没门。总会有出路的。他对我说，你以为你很——我对他说，不，好吧，太糟糕了。我不会让自己被抓到的。我说，你做你的工作，我做我的工作，我们会开心地回家。
That's when Jassiel took his clothes off, jumped in the river, and swam across to safety.
就在那时，贾西尔脱掉衣服，跳进河里，游向安全地带。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
You need to come back, and we need to catch you. And I said, yes, but today was not your day, man.
你需要回来，我们需要抓住你。我说，是的，但今天不是你们的日子，伙计。
Sometimes Jassiel videotapes his crossings and his narrow escapes. It's like proof of how good he is at the job, and a chance to show off. Even though the job is illegal, they post the stuff all the time on Snapchat and Facebook, like this one video Jassiel sent me. It's of him crossing a big group of migrants.
有时贾西尔会录下他的过境和惊险逃脱过程。这就像证明他有多擅长这份工作，也是一个炫耀的机会。尽管这份工作是非法的，他们还是会一直把这些东西发在Snapchat和Facebook上，就像贾西尔发给我的这段视频。这是他运送一大群移民的视频。
[SHOUTING IN SPANISH]
[用西班牙语大喊]
They're running through a farm on a dirt road. He's yelling, go, go, go, you didn't come here to stay, at the slowest one, a young woman with short brown hair. Her arms are flailing, like she's at the end of a marathon.
他们正在土路上跑过一个农场。他对着最慢的一个——一个留着棕色短发的年轻女性大喊，快，快，快，你不是来这里待着的。她的手臂胡乱挥舞，就像在马拉松终点一样。
She's running barefoot, holding her shoes. But even though this whole thing feels so intense, Jassiel stops to crouch down on his knees. It looks like he's going for a more dramatic camera angle.
她光着脚跑，手里拿着鞋。但即使这一切感觉非常紧张，贾西尔还是停下来跪下。看起来他是在寻求更戏剧性的摄像角度。
[SHOUTING IN SPANISH]
[用西班牙语大喊]
A white Jeep Cherokee pulls up, and about 15 migrants pile in. And then, the video cuts off.
一辆白色吉普切诺基开过来，大约15名移民挤了进去。然后，视频中断了。
[SHOUTING IN SPANISH]
[用西班牙语大喊]
I asked Jassiel if word of his exploits had spread. Like, is he famous among the other smugglers?
我问贾西尔他的名声是否已经传开了。比如，他在其他走私犯中很有名吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Yes. Yes, there are a lot-- I mean, there are two songs about me and my brother.
是的。是的，有很多——我是说，有两首歌是关于我和我哥哥的。
First, I was like, yeah, right. And then, he sent me a link. It was a slickly produced song with a video. Like some of the other kid smugglers, he'd commissioned a local rapper to write it. Because if you're 15 and making thousands of a day, why not? Every day, we're crossing the whole border, the chorus goes.
起初，我想，是啊，没错。然后，他发给我一个链接。那是一首制作精良的歌曲，配有视频。像其他一些少年走私犯一样，他委托当地的说唱歌手写了这首歌。因为如果你15岁，每天赚几千块，为什么不呢？每天，我们都在横跨整个边境，副歌唱道。
[SONG IN SPANISH]
[西班牙语歌曲]
Here's the part where they name-check Jassiel and his brother.
这是他们提到贾西尔和他哥哥名字的部分。
[SONG IN SPANISH]
[西班牙语歌曲]
I spent six months talking to dozens of these kids. And there was one in particular who everyone kept talking about. He's the one who's been at it the longest, who's crossed the most people. And he's just, kind of, fearless about how he does it. He asked me to change his name, so I'm calling him Antonio. We're also altering his voice.
我花了六个月时间与这些孩子中的几十个谈话。其中有一个人大家一直在谈论。他是做得最久、运送人数最多的那个人。而且他在做事方式上相当无畏。他要求我更改他的名字，所以我叫他安东尼奥。我们也对他的声音进行了处理。
He's become a master of his craft, the Michael Jordan of smuggling. He learned about the job when he was 12 when he was just a little kid with a buzz cut, wearing a school uniform.
他已经成为这门手艺的大师，走私界的迈克尔·乔丹。他12岁时就知道了这份工作，那时候他还是个留着平头、穿着校服的小孩。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Well, I was coming out of school-- I was in, like, the sixth grade, and I was walking. And well, I bumped into a friend who was older than me, and he said, I'm headed to work. He was dressed in full camouflage, like a soldier, and I said, damn, you're going to work? What kind of work?
嗯，我放学出来——我当时在六年级，我在走路。然后，我碰见了一个比我大的朋友，他说，我要去工作了。他穿着全套迷彩服，像个士兵，我说，天哪，你要去工作？什么样的工作？
And he said, I take goats to the other side. And I said, [BLEEP] you take animals over there or what? He said, nah, man, I take people over there. They pay me. They pay me in dollars.
他说，我把羊带到那边去。我说，[哔]你带动物过去还是怎么着？他说，不，伙计，我把人带过去。他们付钱给我。他们用美元付钱。
He's been at it five years now. The way some kids study game tape, that's how Antonio approaches migration, even if his tactics can sometimes sound, kind of, callous.
他已经干了五年了。就像有些孩子研究比赛录像一样，这就是安东尼奥对待移民的方式，即使他的战术有时听起来有些冷酷。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I always ask for, like, the skinny immigrants, know what I'm saying?
我总是要求找那些瘦小的移民，懂我意思吗？
Wait, why skinny?
等等，为什么是瘦小的？
So that they can run like I can. Because if immigration is chasing me or something, I'm not going to wait for anyone. Well, I've always worked with a big number of people. I've never worked with a small group of persons, know what I'm saying?
这样他们就能跑得像我一样快。因为如果有移民局在追我什么的，我不会等任何人的。嗯，我一直和一大群人一起工作。我从没和少数人一起工作过，懂我意思吗？
He learned all the curves in the river, and all the tricks, how to brush away the footprints, wear camouflage. He memorized the patrol schedule of the immigration agents. One day, we were talking about his favorite crossing points, and he started describing the map of this part of South Texas that he'd built in his head, street by street.
他学会了河里所有的弯道和所有的技巧，如何扫去足迹，穿迷彩服。他背下了移民局特工的巡逻时间表。有一天，我们谈到他最喜欢的过境点，他开始描述他脑海中建立的南得克萨斯这一带的地图，一条街一条街地。
He'd memorized the city parks, the local high schools, the places where the mesquite trees are thickest, in case he needs a place to hide. Antonio was never great at school or sports, but this, he'd found his thing. Even his stepfather asked him to smuggle him across.
他记住了城市公园、当地高中，以及如果需要躲藏的地方，那些牧豆树最茂密的地方。安东尼奥在学校或体育方面从不出色，但在这个，他找到了自己的强项。甚至他的继父也让他帮忙偷运过境。
Antonio was 17. And despite a couple of new tattoos, he looks like a kid. Many of the migrants are decades older than he is, tired from the thousands of miles they've already traveled.
安东尼奥17岁。尽管有几个新纹身，但他看起来还是个孩子。许多移民比他大几十岁，因为已经走了几千英里而精疲力尽。
So he tries to puff himself up to seem taller than 5' 5". He thinks of Al Pacino's character in Scarface, his favorite movie. Before the trip even begins, Antonio sits the migrants down and launches into a pep talk. He tries to sound commanding.
所以他试图让自己看起来比5英尺5英寸更高。他想到阿尔·帕西诺在《疤面煞星》中的角色，这是他最喜欢的电影。在旅程开始之前，安东尼奥让移民坐下来，开始发表励志演说。他试图让自己听起来很有指挥力。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
You see, I say, in a little while, in the forest, we're all gonna walk along my path, all very hidden, crouching down, without making a peep. Now, in less than 10 minutes, we're going to go over the wall. And when we go over the wall, the guys picking us up will be waiting for us. And after climbing down, we're going to take you to a warehouse, and we soon will be on the other side, eating some really good food.
你看，我说，过一会儿，在森林里，我们将沿着我的路径行走，所有人都要非常隐蔽，蹲下，不要发出一点声音。现在，在不到10分钟内，我们将翻过那堵墙。当我们翻过去时，接应我们的人会在那里等着。爬下来后，我们会带你们去一个仓库，很快我们就会到达另一边，吃上很棒的食物。
Antonio loves to brag about how good a smuggler he is, how hard he is to catch. Some of the other kids roll their eyes at what a loud mouth he is. He dropped out of middle school to focus on smuggling.
安东尼奥喜欢吹嘘他作为一个走私犯有多厉害，有多难被抓住。其他一些孩子对他这种大嘴巴嗤之以鼻。他从中学退学专注于走私。
With his earnings, he bought a closet full of Air Force Ones and a car, a Ford Focus. He gave his mom an allowance. She told me it helped pay the rent and cover household expenses.
用赚来的钱，他买了一柜子的空军一号鞋和一辆福特福克斯。他给妈妈生活费。她告诉我这有助于付房租和支付家庭开支。
But Antonio and the other kids are aware that they're doing the work of the Gulf Cartel, which controls the border. The Justice Department calls it one of the most violent and brutal drug-trafficking organizations in the world. Antonio knew who those guys were, the big bosses.
但安东尼奥和其他孩子意识到他们正在为海湾贩毒集团工作，该集团控制着边境。司法部称它是世界上最暴力和残忍的贩毒组织之一。安东尼奥知道那些人是谁，那些大老板。
They yelled at him when he screwed up and got caught. Sometimes they pressured him to do more dangerous work, like take drugs across in big bags. They sent him text messages. come on, man, do another run for us. Every time he says yes, Antonio gets closer to them.
当他搞砸被抓时，他们对他大喊大叫。有时他们强迫他做更危险的工作，比如把毒品装在大袋子里运过去。他们给他发短信。来吧，伙计，再帮我们跑一趟。每次他答应，安东尼奥就离他们更近一步。
The border patrol are watching this play out every day. The agents spend much of their days chasing around juvenile smugglers, and then just spitting them back into Mexico hours later. Some have been caught more than 100 times, but they just keep going.
边境巡逻队每天都在注视着这一切发生。特工们大部分时间都在追捕少年走私犯，然后几个小时后就把他们扔回墨西哥。有些人被抓过100多次，但他们还是不停地干。
The agents even put photos of the top kids on the walls of their office. I learned that from a senior border patrol agent in South Texas and his partner. He asked that we not include his name.
特工们甚至把顶尖孩子的照片贴在办公室墙上。我是从南得克萨斯州的一位高级边境巡逻特工和他搭档那里知道的。他要求我们不要透露他的名字。
We have our list. So we have our list of top 10 kids.
我们有我们的名单。所以我们有一份前10名的孩子名单。
Wait, you have, literally, a list of 10 kids? Like, the 10 most wanted-- not most wanted, but 10 most productive kids?
等等，你们真的有一份10个孩子的名单？就像，10个通缉犯——不是通缉犯，而是10个最高产的孩子？
Yes, sir.
是的，先生。
Why? What does that do for you guys?
为什么？这对你们有什么用？
I mean, we just keep track.
我是说，我们只是追踪记录。
Can you tell me, like, is the list on the wall of the office somewhere? Or like--
你能告诉我，名单是在办公室墙上的某个地方吗？或者像——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
(CHUCKLING) In my office, yeah.
（轻笑）在我的办公室，是的。
Is it really?
真的吗？
Yes.
是的。
We were sitting in a conference room in the border patrol office, about 30 feet from the Rio Grande. The agent was across the table from me. And when he talked about the teenage smugglers, it was with a kind of mix of amusement and annoyance.
我们当时坐在边境巡逻办公室的一个会议室里，距离格兰德河大约30英尺。特工坐在我对面。当他谈到少年走私犯时，混合着一种好笑和恼火的感觉。
Like, I can't believe this is my job, chasing a bunch of kids. I asked the agent if he knew the kid we were calling Antonio. He just smirked.
比如，我不敢相信这是我的工作，追逐一群孩子。我问特工他是否认识我们叫安东尼奥的那个孩子。他只是假笑了一下。
Like, there's one kid in particular that I've been spending time with, who I feel like you probably know. His name's [BLEEP]
比如，有个孩子我特别花时间相处，我觉得你可能认识。他的名字是[哔]
What about him?
他怎么样？
Is he on the top 10 list?
他是在前10名的名单上吗？
I wouldn't really want to answer that, to be honest with you. Yeah.
说实话，我真的不想回答那个问题。是的。
Is there anything you can tell me about him?
关于他你有什么能告诉我的吗？
Just that he-- I mean, he's good at what he did, you know.
只是他——我是说，他在他做的事上很擅长，你知道。
You think he's out of the game?
你觉得他退出这行了吗？
I'm not sure, to be honest with you.
说实话，我不确定。
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, he was careful at what he was doing. He knew what he was doing. He was one of those kids maybe that it's like, hey, I got you three days ago, and you will laugh it out, and it was, kind of, like that funny but annoying. Like, you were just like, man, you know, we got you next time, or we got you this time, kind of deal.
我是说，他在做的事情上很小心。他知道他在做什么。他可能是那种你会说，嘿，三天前我抓到你了，你会笑出来的孩子，这有点那种滑稽但令人恼火的感觉。就像，你只是说，伙计，你知道，下次我们再抓你，或者这次我们抓到你了，这样的事情。
To him, it, kind of, feels fruitless. The border patrol's mission is to stop illegal migration, and here he is in the front lines, just catching the same kids every day. He gives them food.
对他来说，这感觉有点徒劳。边境巡逻队的任务是阻止非法移民，而他就在前线，每天都在抓同样的孩子。他给他们食物。
Sometimes the kids lose their shoes in the mud, so he gives them these border patrol flip-flops. Then the kids are just sent back home. And it's like, OK, see you in a few days.
有时孩子们在泥里丢了鞋子，所以他会给他们这些边境巡逻队的拖鞋。然后孩子们又被送回家了。就像，好了，几天后再见。
I mean, you're hoping that-- kind of, like a teacher, right? You're, kind of, hoping that when you talk to these kids and tell them, hey, man, you know, next time, this can happen.
我是说，你希望——就像一位老师，对吧？你有点希望当你和这些孩子谈话并告诉他们，嘿，伙计，你知道，下次，这种情况可能会发生。
You can end up drowning. You can end up-- something bad can happen, you need to start behaving. And you're hoping that maybe it sinks to one of them.
你可能会淹死。你可能会——坏事可能会发生，你需要开始表现好点。你希望这可能对其中一个孩子有影响。
The massive record of apprehensions each of these kids has, it's only relevant when they turn 18. If they're caught then, prosecutors can try to use that history against them. One agent told me his colleagues celebrated the 18th birthdays of the most prolific kids, and high-five them in the office. Until then, there's not much that they can do.
这些孩子每个人背后的巨额记录，只有在他们年满18岁时才相关。如果那时被抓到，检察官可以尝试用那段历史来对付他们。一位特工告诉我，他的同事会庆祝最顽固孩子的18岁生日，并在办公室里和他们击掌。在那之前，他们能做的并不多。
The agent, after he catches the kids, takes them to Mexican authorities, who take them to the small shelter about 400 yards from the border. I was at the shelter one day, and in walked Alfonso, one of the brothers from the song, with a bunch of other smugglers who had just been apprehended and released by border patrol.
这位特工在抓住孩子们后，把他们带给墨西哥当局，他们把孩子们带到距离边境大约400码的一个小收容所。有一天我在收容所，歌里的兄弟之一阿方索走了进来，还有一群刚被边境巡逻队逮捕和释放的其他走私犯。
They were all sitting on plastic chairs in the shelter's lobby. It felt like high school detention-- a group of boys, kind of, proud of themselves for getting in trouble, punching each other in the shoulders, waiting for their moms to pick them up. A woman at the shelter named Perla Sustaita processed Alfonso the same way she had many times before.
他们都坐在收容所大厅的塑料椅子上。感觉就像高中的留校察看——一群男孩，有点为自己惹上麻烦而感到自豪，互相捶打肩膀，等着他们的妈妈来接他们。收容所里一位叫佩拉·苏斯塔塔的女士像往常一样处理了阿方索。
It was his 13th apprehension. She had the blasé expressions of a very tired assistant principal, asking questions from a script she had memorized. She typed up the answers in the shelter system.
这是他第13次被捕。她有着非常疲惫的助理校长的冷漠表情，问着她背下来的剧本里的问题。她把答案输入收容所的系统。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
How did you cross the river? When did they detain you? Why did you cross? She asks, while Alfonso answers flatly. And then, he waited for his mom to come pick him up.
你是怎么过河的？他们什么时候拘留你的？你为什么过境？她问，而阿方索平淡地回答。然后，他等着他妈妈来接他。
All these kids know that they have only until their 18th birthday, and then their loophole disappears. So they all have to decide what they're going to do next. Israel, the one with the wispy mustache, was 17 when we spoke. He told me that even though he still had time left before turning 18, he was definitely done.
所有这些孩子都知道他们只有到18岁生日为止，然后他们的漏洞就消失了。所以他们都必须决定下一步该怎么做。那个留着稀疏胡子的以色列，我们交谈时17岁。他告诉我，尽管在满18岁之前他还有时间，但他绝对不会再干了。
No. Not again. I'm fine with my girlfriend, you know what I mean? Getting caught, and losing seven, eight years of being with my family, with my grandmother, with my dad-- my grandmother is old.
不。不要再来了。我和我的女朋友相处得很好，你知道我的意思吗？被抓到，失去七八年和我的家人、我的祖母、我的爸爸在一起的时间——我的祖母老了。
Like, can you imagine if they locked me up, and suddenly I get a call telling me, your grandmother died? No. I'd rather spend my time here, calm. I prefer not to have money and be free. I'm at peace now.
比如，你能想象如果他们把我关起来，突然我接到电话告诉我，你祖母去世了吗？不。我宁愿把时间花在这里，平静地。我宁愿没钱也要自由。我现在很平静。
He hasn't crossed the border for months now. Most kids stop when they're 17. They move on with their lives. Instead of bringing people across the border, they get jobs in the giant factories that send windshield wipers and steering wheels to the US.
他已经好几个月没越境了。大多数孩子在17岁时就会停止。他们继续他们的生活。他们不再运送人们越过边境，而是去工厂找工作，那些工厂向美国发送雨刮器和方向盘。
Some try to smuggle themselves to the United States and stay there. That was Alfonso's plan, the brother from the song who I'd seen getting processed at the border. Then, there's Antonio, the one that the border patrol told me they were tired of chasing.
有些人试图偷运自己去美国并待在那里。那是阿方索的计划，那个我在边境处理过程中看到的歌里的兄弟。然后，还有安东尼奥，边境巡逻队告诉我他们厌倦了追捕的那个人。
As he got closer to his 18th birthday, he started posting photos of himself holding an assault rifle on Facebook. He talked about his links to the Gulf Cartel and the methamphetamines he was taking. I'd been talking to him for months, sometimes in person and sometimes over the phone.
当他接近18岁生日时，他开始在Facebook上发布自己拿着突击步枪的照片。他谈到了他与海湾贩毒集团的联系以及他正在服用的甲基苯丙胺。我跟他谈了几个月，有时是亲自谈，有时是通过电话谈。
Often, I'd call, and he'd puzzle through his next steps. Maybe he'd work fixing laptops, he said. Maybe if he walked away from the cartel, his sisters would help him with some money.
通常，我会打电话，他会思索他的下一步。也许他会去修笔记本电脑，他说。也许如果他离开贩毒集团，他的姐妹们会给他一些钱。
Oh, and did I know any American girls he could marry? He asked me once. Another day, bored at home, he changed his profession on Facebook to border patrol agent. He just seemed kind of unmoored.
哦，我认识他可以娶的美国女孩吗？他有一次问我。又有一天，在家无聊时，他把Facebook上的职业改成了边境巡逻特工。他看起来有点漂泊无依。
Then, one day, not too long ago, I called to see how he was doing.
然后，有一天，不久前，我打电话看他过得怎么样。
Soy Kevin, el periodista, como estas?
我是凯文，记者，你好吗？
Ey, estoy bien, que onda?
嘿，我很好，怎么样？
That sound in the background there, he told me that was a pistol.
背景里的那个声音，他告诉我那是手枪。
Soy cargando la pistola.
我正在给手枪装弹。
Las pistolas?
手枪？
Si, hoy.
是的，今天。
Y qué vas a hacer con las pistolas?
你要用手枪做什么？
Hoy vamos a ir a matar a una gente.
今天我们要去杀人。
No.
不。
He told me he was going to kill someone, and that he was getting paid to do it. A truck arrived to pick him up, and the call ended abruptly. I didn't know where he was, or where he was going, or any details of his plan.
他告诉我他要去杀人，而且他因为做这件事得到了报酬。一辆卡车来接他，电话突然中断了。我不知道他在哪里，或者他要去哪里，也不知道他计划的任何细节。
I called Antonio the next day to see what happened. He told me he'd gone on the hit and fired his gun, but missed. His friend was shot, but survived, and they ran off.
我第二天打电话给安东尼奥看发生了什么。他告诉我他去了行凶并开了枪，但没打中。他的朋友中弹了，但活了下来，他们跑开了。
Then, a few days later, Antonio was taken by armed men from his mother's house in the middle of the night. He was handcuffed and beaten for three days. I went to visit him at his house, a one-bedroom apartment about a mile from the border, not far from the industrial corridor that has sprouted up since NAFTA.
然后，几天后，安东尼奥在半夜被武装人员从他母亲家里带走。他被戴上手铐并殴打了三天。我去看望他，在他位于边境一英里外的一间一居室公寓里，离北美自由贸易协定以来建起来的工业走廊不远。
He sleeps on a mattress in the kitchen, under a poster of The Last Supper. There were still scars around his wrists from where he'd been handcuffed. No one could explain why he'd been targeted.
他睡在厨房的床垫上，就在一张《最后的晚餐》海报下面。他手腕上还有戴手铐留下的伤疤。没人能解释他为什么成为目标。
Antonio told me it was because he was high on pills, and the cartel doesn't allow that. But it seemed likely to me that it had something to do with his shift from teenage smuggler to hit man, and the botched mission. He's still getting messages beckoning him back to smuggling.
安东尼奥告诉我这是因为他嗑药了，而贩毒集团不允许那样。但我觉得这很可能与他从少年走私犯转变为职业杀手以及任务失败有关。他还在收到诱惑他回去走私的消息。
The other day, he got one. Do you want to cross another group? He turns 18 in February. These days, he catches himself looking at his snapshots, like an old man looking through photos of vacations he took when he was young.
前几天，他收到了一条。你想再运送一群人吗？他在二月满18岁。这些天，他发现自己看着他的快照，就像一个老人翻看他年轻时度假的照片。
I asked him why they were so important to him. Just to remember what I did, he said. To remember what I did in life.
我问他为什么它们对他那么重要。只是为了记住我做过什么，他说。记住我在生活中做过什么。
Kevin Sieff. He's a reporter for The Washington Post. He also did a print version of this story, with pictures and videos, and they're great. And you can find it online.
凯文·西夫。《华盛顿邮报》的记者。他还做了这个故事的印刷版，配有图片和视频，非常棒。你可以在网上找到它。
If you want to hear more of Kevin's stories, he's often on Post Reports, The Washington Post's daily news podcast. You can find it at postreports.com or wherever you get your podcasts.
如果你想听到更多凯文的故事，他经常出现在《邮报报道》上，这是《华盛顿邮报》的每日新闻播客。你可以在postreports.com或任何你获取播客的地方找到它。
Act 2, The Last Ride. So reading up this week about the best-known ferrymen in the world, the one from Greek mythology, Charon, what's striking about him is, it's really hard to find many details about what that trip across the river was like, with Charon guiding the boat to the Underworld. Like, what happens in that boat?
第二幕，最后一次旅程。所以这周读了关于世界上最著名的摆渡人，来自希腊神话的卡戎，令人震惊的是，很难找到关于跨越河流那次旅程是什么样子的细节，卡戎引导船只前往冥界。比如，那条船上发生了什么？
Conversations, fistfights, acting out, sullen moping? Like, what happens? And what's it like for Charon, making that same trip over and over for all eternity, transporting everyone who has ever lived?
对话，拳脚相向，胡闹，郁闷地生闷气？比如，发生了什么？对于卡戎来说，永恒地重复着同样的旅程，运送每一个曾经活过的人，那是什么感觉？
Well, the writer Marie Phillips was kind enough to sketch it out for us. Her story is read by actor Noma Dumezweni.
嗯，作家玛丽·菲利普斯很好心地为我们勾勒出来了。她的故事由演员诺玛·杜梅兹温尼朗读。
Deep in the belly of the Underworld, the River Styx oozed like a deadly snake, black water glistening like scales. All around was darkness, heavy and sulphurous.
在冥界的深处，斯堤克斯河像一条致命的蛇一样渗出，黑色的水像鳞片一样闪闪发光。四周是一片黑暗，沉重且充满硫磺味。
The gloom echoed with the wailing of doomed souls, those unable to pay the single coin demanded by Charon, the ferryman, who'd pluck it from his passengers' mouths with a thick, crooked finger. Charon's oar propelled the boat through the water, lapping and lapping like a-- like a cat, drinking milk, thought Mrs. Ruth Langley of Basingstoke, Great Britain, recently deceased at 83 from a stroke suffered while dusting her husband's collection of miniature model warplanes.
阴沉中回荡着注定失败的灵魂的哀号，那些无法支付摆渡人卡戎要求的单枚硬币的人，他会用粗壮、弯曲的手指从乘客嘴里抠出硬币。卡戎的桨推动船只划过水面，拍打着，拍打着，像一只——像一只猫在喝牛奶，露丝·兰利夫人想道，来自英国贝辛斯托克，最近刚因中风去世，享年83岁，当时她正在擦拭她丈夫收藏的微型军用飞机模型。
Mrs. Langley had never had a cat, let alone listened to one drink. Her husband had allergies. Mrs. Langley believed in being prompt. She'd been the first on the boat, taking her seat at the very front, next to the mysterious oarsman, a hulking giant with a furrowed brow, his hooded eyes fixed on the horizon.
兰利夫人从来没养过猫，更别说听猫喝水了。她丈夫过敏。兰利夫人相信准时。她是第一个上船的，坐在最前面，紧靠着神秘的划桨手，一个弓着眉、体型庞大的巨人，他戴着兜帽的眼睛盯着地平线。
He seemed, she thought, a little ill at ease. "This is nice, isn't it?" She said. "I always wanted to go on a cruise." Charon said nothing. "The Mediterranean or the Greek Islands. You must know all about them, of course. Are they wonderful?" Charon said nothing.
她觉得他似乎有点局促不安。“这感觉真不错，不是吗？”她说。“我一直想去乘游轮。”卡戎什么也没说。“地中海或希腊群岛。你一定非常了解它们，当然。它们很奇妙吗？”卡戎什么也没说。
"I always pictured myself sunbathing on deck while a handsome waiter brought me glasses of amaretto. I wonder what amaretto tastes like. Have you ever had it? It sounds so romantic, amaretto. I suppose there'll be plenty of opportunity to try new drinks once we get there." Charon said nothing.
“我一直想象自己在甲板上晒日光浴，同时一个英俊的服务员给我拿来阿马雷托酒。我不知道阿马雷托是什么味道。你喝过吗？听起来很浪漫，阿马雷托。我想一旦我们到达那里，会有很多机会尝试新饮料。”卡戎什么也没说。
"Well, anyway, my husband hates boats. Oh, I don't mean to offend. I'm sure when his time comes, he'll think this one is lovely." She glanced behind her to the cowering mortals weeping and screaming and clutching at one another in despair, then turned back to her host.
“好吧，总之，我丈夫讨厌船。哦，我不是故意冒犯。我相信当他的时间到了，他会觉得这艘船很可爱。”她回头看了看后面畏缩着哭泣、尖叫并绝望地抓住彼此的凡人，然后转回她的主人。
"It's really motion sickness that's his problem. And this is a very smooth ride. You have a wonderful technique. You should be very proud." Charon said nothing.
“晕船才是他的问题。而且这是一次非常平稳的旅程。你的技术太棒了。你应该感到很自豪。”卡戎什么也没说。
"Is it exciting, meeting all the famous people? It must be. Did you speak to Princess Diana? What was she like? I've always thought she seemed so compassionate, like Mother Teresa, but chic." Charon said nothing.
“见到所有名人令人兴奋吗？一定是吧。你和戴安娜王妃谈过吗？她是什么样子的？我一直觉得她看起来很有同情心，像特蕾莎修女，但更时髦。”卡戎什么也没说。
"You know what I think is a really nice touch? No first class. We're all literally in the same boat. You never know who you might end up sitting next to, though it looks like nobody famous died today. Oh, well. Oh, but I'm very happy up here with you, no complaints." Charon said nothing.
“你知道我认为一个非常贴心的细节是什么吗？没有头等舱。我们真的都在同一条船上。你永远不知道你最后会和谁坐在一起，尽管看起来今天没有名人去世。哦，好吧。哦，但我在这里和你在一起很开心，没什么抱怨。”卡戎什么也没说。
Mrs. Langley gazed out into the murk. Her hands twitched in her lap, where her handbag ought to be. "I don't suppose," she said, "you remember a man called John Farmer?
兰利夫人凝视着阴影。她的手在膝盖上抽动，本来应该在那里放个手提包。“我不认为，”她说，“你还记得一个叫约翰·法默的男人吗？
About mid-height, sandy hair, died in 1994 after a bus hit him? It made the local paper. He used to take me to dances when I was a girl. He made me laugh, held my hand.
中等身高，沙色头发，1994年被公共汽车撞死后去世？当地报纸登过。我年轻的时候他常带我去跳舞。他让我笑，握着我的手。
He wanted to marry me, but I thought there was more out there. I always wondered, what if? So I thought maybe if you drop me off where he is-- oh, of course, he moved on. But his wife, Linda, is still alive.
他想娶我，但我以为外面有更广阔的世界。我一直想，如果……会怎样？所以我想到也许如果你把我送到他在的地方——哦，当然，他已经走了。但他妻子琳达还在世。
She remarried a software engineer from Penzance. Younger man. And then, there's my husband, not here yet, but soon enough. Probably enjoying the silence up there, haha.
她嫁给了一个来自彭赞斯的软件工程师。年轻的男人。还有我丈夫，虽然还没到，但很快也会来。可能在上面享受安静，哈哈。
Always did say I talk too much. But he loves me. I suppose that will all be quite complicated here. Love." Charon said nothing.
总是说我话太多。但他爱我。我想在这里一切都会很复杂。爱。”卡戎什么也没说。
"John probably wouldn't look at me twice now anyway. I'm an old lady." Charon said nothing. Mrs. Langley looked up at the ferryman.
“反正约翰现在可能都不会再看我一眼了。我是个老太婆。”卡戎什么也没说。兰利夫人抬头看着摆渡人。
There was something so dignified in the way that he stood there, rowing implacably onwards. "You're a really good listener," she said. Charon turned towards her.
他站在那里坚定不移地划桨的样子里有一种如此尊严的东西。“你真是个很好的倾听者，”她说。卡戎转向她。
The woman talked. They always did. Every trip without fail. One of immortals would detach itself from the group, attach itself to him, and start chattering. It never changed.
女人总是说话。她们总是这样。每次旅程从不例外。不朽者中的一员会从群体中脱离，依附于他，开始喋喋不休。从没改变过。
Sure, they were different mortals, but how different were they, really? It was like a swarm of rats. You could probably tell them apart if you look closely, but who'd want to do that? The woman talked.
当然，她们是不同的凡人，但她们真的有那么不同吗？这就像一群老鼠。如果你仔细看可能还能分辨出它们，但谁会想那样做呢？女人说话。
Most of the time, they were begging and pleading. They were so desperate to be returned to that thing they called life. They hadn't caught on yet, that life, or existence at least, was the one thing that they had in abundance. For all eternity, in fact.
大多数时候，她们在乞求和哀求。她们是那么渴望回到那个她们称之为生活的东西。她们还没意识到，生命，或者至少存在，是她们唯一拥有的东西。事实上是永恒的。
Charon had some things to say on the subject of eternal life, should he ever feel inclined to speak. Notably, that it went on for a very long time. But Charon did not feel inclined to speak. Who would he speak to? The rats?
对于永生这个主题，如果卡戎有心情说话的话，他有一些话要说。值得注意的是，它会持续很长很长时间。但卡戎不想说话。他会对谁说话？那些老鼠？
The woman talked. Love was the other thing they never shut up about. Each of them thinks that their own love is so special, so unique, that their love never dies. They're about to get a lesson in undying love, all right.
女人说话。爱是她们喋喋不休的另一件事。她们每个人都认为自己的爱是如此特别，如此独特，以至于她们的爱永不消逝。她们很快就会学到关于不朽之爱的一课了。
There was a reason the gods specialized in transient passions that burned hot and fast, and usually ended up with the other person turned into an animal. But maybe it wouldn't be so bad, a companion. A still, silent presence in this maelstrom of mortal jibber jabber, someone to share the long nights, the glide of the boat through the water, the velvet embrace of the darkness, the sweet music of abandoned souls sobbing in misery.
神灵们专注于那种燃烧得热烈而迅速、通常以对方变成动物而告终的瞬间激情是有原因的。但也许这不会太糟糕，一个同伴。在这个凡人胡言乱语的漩涡中，一个安静、无声的存在，一个人分享漫漫长夜，船在水中滑行，黑暗的丝绒拥抱，被遗弃的灵魂在苦难中啜泣的甜美音乐。
A few words floated out from the talking woman. "He made me laugh, held my hand." Charon's hand was so callous from manning the oar that it resembled stone. Someone to hold his hand. Yes. He could see the value in that.
几个词从那个说话的女人嘴里飘出来。“他让我笑，握着我的手。”卡戎的手因为操桨而长满老茧，看起来像石头一样。一个人握住他的手。是的。他能看到其中的价值。
"You're a really good listener," she said. He looked down at her, small, frail. Her hair puffed up in a piteous attempt at prettiness. Wide eyes searching his, lips softly parted.
“你真是个很好的倾听者，”她说。他低下头看着她，娇小，脆弱。她的头发蓬松着，试图显得漂亮。大眼睛搜索着他的眼睛，嘴唇微微张开。
He gently took her chin, then shoved his finger into her mouth and felt around. No coin. He tossed her into the water. Never any coins these days. Still, he had to check. He reached out his hand and beckoned the next mortal towards him.
他轻轻捏住她的下巴，然后把手指伸进她的嘴里摸索。没有硬币。他把她扔进水里。这些日子从来没有硬币。尽管如此，他还是得检查一下。他伸出手，示意下一个凡人向他走来。
Actor Noma Dumezweni, reading a story by Marie Phillips, who has, by the way, a whole novel about the Greek gods, living in contemporary London, behaving badly, called Gods Behaving Badly. Her latest book is Create Your Own Midlife Crisis. Coming up, somebody whose job it is to get living people from one place to another, past a massive barrier put in place by a dead man to stop them. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
演员诺玛·杜梅兹温尼朗读玛丽·菲利普斯的故事，顺便说一句，玛丽·菲利普斯有一本关于希腊神灵居住在当代伦敦行为恶劣的整本小说，叫《神灵行为恶劣》。她最新的书是《创造你自己的中年危机》。接下来，一个职责是将活着的人从一个地方运送到另一个地方，越过死人为了阻止他们而设置的巨大障碍的人。那是芝加哥公共广播电台在我们的节目继续时的一分钟后的内容。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, "The Ferryman," stories about people whose job it is to transport us from point A to point B and what that's like for them, what happens along the way. We've arrived at Act 3 of our program. Act 3, Better Call Dave.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“摆渡人”，讲述那些运送我们从A点到B点的人的故事，这对他们来说是什么感觉，沿途发生了什么。我们已经到达了节目的第三幕。第三幕，最好叫戴夫。
So this next story, the point A and point B that the person has to travel between are not far apart at all. And yet, it's a really hard job. It requires a lot of special knowledge and specialized skills, particularly this one time when he was hired to take the living across to get to the treasures of the dead. David Kestenbaum explains.
所以下一个故事，那个人必须穿行的A点和B点一点也不远。然而，这是一份非常艰巨的工作。它需要大量的专业知识和专门技能，特别是当他受雇将生者运送过去以获取死者宝藏的这一次。大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆解释道。
I met Dave McOmie because I had a bank vault I needed opened, just for fun. My friend worked in a building that had once been a bank, and it happened to have this abandoned vault in the basement. It was locked, and we wanted to see what was in it.
我遇到戴夫·麦科米是因为我有一个银行金库需要打开，纯粹是为了好玩。我的朋友在一个曾经是银行的建筑里工作，碰巧地下室里有一个废弃的金库。它是锁着的，我们想看看里面有什么。
We still haven't gotten to that. But in our search for someone to open it for us, I met Dave, who had this one, kind of, amazing story I wanted you to hear. Dave is a safecracker, one of the best. He keeps his tools-- where else? A safe.
我们还没做到那一步。但在寻找帮我们打开它的人时，我遇到了戴夫，他有一个让我很想让你听听的、令人惊叹的故事。戴夫是一位保险箱专家，最出色的人之一。他把他的工具放在哪儿？一个保险箱里。
How long would it take you to break into your own safe?
打开你自己的保险箱需要多长时间？
Well, the problem with that is that my tools I would need to break into the safe are in the safe. So that's a bit of a conundrum, I guess.
嗯，问题在于我打开保险箱所需的工具在那个保险箱里。所以我猜这有点自相矛盾。
Dave told me he got interested in opening things that were not supposed to be opened when he was 15. A neighbor had lost her car keys, or had her purse stolen with the keys in them, so she'd called the locksmith. The guy came over. Dave watched him work and was like, that's a job?
戴夫告诉我，他15岁时对打开不该被打开的东西产生了兴趣。一位邻居丢了车钥匙，或者手提包被偷了，钥匙在里面，所以她叫了锁匠。那个人过来了。戴夫看着他工作，心想，这是一份工作？
He was fascinated, ended up as a kind of apprentice in the man's shop. In Dave's telling, he was, kind of, a gentleman safecracker.
他着迷了，最终成了那个人店里的学徒。在戴夫的描述中，他有点像绅士保险箱专家。
Dave always called him, Mr. Corey. He did locks, safes, vaults. Dave says he was not a natural at it at all. He still, kind of, feels that way.
戴夫总是称呼他为，科里先生。他修理锁、保险箱、金库。戴夫说他根本不是这方面的天才。他仍然觉得是这样。
Well, the truth is, I'm still not very mechanical. I take much longer to figure things out than most of my friends do.
嗯，事实是，我仍然不是很擅长机械。我比我的大多数朋友花更多时间去弄明白事情。
So what do you think makes you good at it?
那么你认为是什么让你擅长这个？
Persistence. Just refusing to give up.
坚持。就是拒绝放弃。
Dave learned how to open safes just by feel and listening. Yeah, that's really a thing. Turning the dial slowly, click by click.
戴夫学会了仅凭感觉和听觉打开保险箱。是的，这确实是真的。慢慢地转动拨盘，咔哒咔哒。
Sometimes you get into a trance, and you wake up hours later when the safe opens, and you realize, oh my god, three hours passed. It felt like 10 minutes. Finally, it pops. And it's a great feeling.
有时你会进入一种出神状态，当你几个小时后醒来时，保险箱打开了，你意识到，天哪，过了三个小时。感觉就像10分钟。最后，它砰地一声打开了。那种感觉太棒了。
Is that the thing you love about the job? Just that it is so satisfying when the thing actually opens for you?
这就是你喜欢这份工作的原因吗？只是因为它真的为你打开时那种满足感？
Yes. There's nothing like it, really. The closest thing would be sex.
是的。没有什么比这更好的了，真的。最接近的大概是性。
That's a terrible comparison.
那是一个糟糕的比较。
I know, but it's true. Opening safes involves--
我知道，但这是真的。打开保险箱涉及——
I feel like you're doing damage to both safe cracking and sex with that comparison.
我觉得你通过那个比较同时破坏了保险箱专家和性。
That's Dave. Dave lives outside Portland, Oregon with his wife and kids, edits a magazine called International Safecracker, teaches safecracking classes. When other safecrackers need help, he's one of the people they ask.
这就是戴夫。戴夫和他的妻子孩子住在俄勒冈州波特兰郊外，编辑一本叫《国际保险箱专家》的杂志，教授保险箱开启课程。当其他保险箱专家需要帮助时，他是他们求助的人之一。
Dave's hard of hearing, so he likes to text. And his phone is filled with requests from people looking to hire him, to break into a bank vault or safe that won't open. Dave has lots of stories.
戴夫听力不好，所以他喜欢发短信。他的手机里塞满了来自人们的请求，雇佣他去打开无法打开的银行金库或保险箱。戴夫有很多故事。
There's the time he had to open a Bank of America vault, so that the guy who's going to get married the next day could retrieve the wedding rings, or the time a teller locked herself in a vault. There are locked safes that people have bought at auction that he's opened-- mostly empty, though one was filled with jewels.
有一次他不得不打开美国银行的金库，好让那个第二天要结婚的家伙取回结婚戒指，或者一次出纳员把自己锁在金库里。他打开过人们在拍卖会上买的锁着的保险箱——大部分是空的，不过有一个装满了珠宝。
He told me a friend once opened a gun safe and found a body inside. In this job I'm going to tell you about, it wasn't clear what it was at the start.
他告诉我一个朋友曾经打开一个枪支保险箱发现里面有一具尸体。在我将要讲给你的这份工作中，起初并不清楚那是什么。
Well, the first email was pretty cryptic. I didn't know what they were talking about, and I ignored him. I didn't even respond. And--
嗯，第一封邮件相当神秘。我不知道他们在说什么，我就忽略了。我甚至没回。然后——
What did it say?
它说了什么？
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉谈话]
I don't remember. I get a lot of emails from cranky people wanting information on a safe or a vault. Well, this one was so cryptic, it didn't even warrant a response, I thought.
我不记得了。我收到很多来自脾气暴躁的人想要保险箱或金库信息的邮件。嗯，这封太神秘了，我觉得甚至不值得回复。
He gets a follow-up email, saying, please respond.
他发了后续邮件，说，请回复。
Then, I get emails from two different companies in the safe and vault business in the Midwest, asking me to please respond to them. Well, at that point, I'm like, what the hell? What's going on here? One of my colleagues said, Dave, think famous person, sudden death, Minneapolis area.
然后，我收到了来自中西部保险箱和金库行业两家不同公司的邮件，让我请回复他们。嗯，在那一点上，我想，搞什么鬼？这里发生什么事了？我的一个同事说，戴夫，想想名人，突然死亡，明尼阿波利斯地区。
It was Prince's vault. Yes, Prince, the musician. He died, and apparently, no one had the combination.
那是王子的金库。是的，王子，那个音乐家。他去世了，显然，没人知道密码。
Well, I got instantly very nervous.
嗯，我立刻变得非常紧张。
Did they tell you what kind of safe it was?
他们告诉你那是什么样的保险箱吗？
I already knew.
我已经知道了。
How did you know what kind of vault Prince had?
你是怎么知道王子有什么样的金库的？
I keep track of these things. Just my job, really. One of his friends had put a photograph of it on the internet a decade earlier.
我关注这些事情。其实只是我的工作。他的一位朋友十年前在互联网上放过一张它的照片。
Of course, he recognized the model.
当然，他认出了型号。
And I was impressed. It's not very often you see a full-blown bank vault in a residence.
我很佩服。在住宅里看到一个完整的银行金库并不常见。
That's what it was?
那就是它？
Yes.
是的。
Prince's vault was a Mosler American Century. Dave says Mosler had been the top manufacturer of safes in the United States for 100 years. This was one of the last ones they made. The vault door he was going to have to open was a formidable thing.
王子的金库是一个莫斯勒美国世纪。戴夫说莫斯勒一直是美国100年来顶尖的保险箱制造商。这是他们制造的最后几个之一。他必须打开的金库门是一个令人生畏的东西。
It's 6 and 1/2 feet tall, 3 and 1/2 feet or 4 feet wide, depending on which version. Weighs in at about 6,000 pounds.
它有6英尺半高，3英尺半或4英尺宽，取决于版本。重量约6000磅。
Whoa.
哇。
It's a monster.
它是个怪物。
You write that it was designed to withstand drills and torches, to repel sophisticated attempts at entry, and brutish forms of attack as well.
你写道它是为了抵抗钻孔和喷灯而设计的，为了击退复杂的进入企图，以及野蛮的攻击形式。
That's right. No burglar has ever defeated a Mosler American Century, not once, ever.
没错。从来没有窃贼击败过莫斯勒美国世纪，一次都没有。
The best safes and vaults have gotten harder to open over the years. When people got good at opening by listening and feeling for little clicks as you turn the dial, manufacturers fixed it so you couldn't do that anymore. When people drilled through the doors, safe and vault makers put in hard plates, a layer in the door that's very hard to drill through.
最好的保险箱和金库多年来变得越来越难打开。当人们擅长通过听和感觉转动拨盘时的轻微咔哒声来打开时，制造商修复了它，这样你就不能那样做了。当人们钻开门时，保险箱和金库制造者装上了硬板，门里的一层非常难钻透。
One inventive iteration of this? A layer of, basically, ball bearings. When the drill hits them, they spin, grab the drill bit, and can break it. This vault, Prince's vault, the Mosler American Century, has an additional layer of protection, even more devious, called--
对此的一个发明性迭代？基本上是一层滚珠轴承。当钻头碰到它们时，它们会旋转，抓住钻头，并可能折断它。这个金库，王子的金库，莫斯勒美国世纪，还有一个额外的保护层，更狡猾，叫——
The mousetrap relocker.
捕鼠器重锁装置。
It's an ingenious way to defeat the burglars.
这是击败窃贼的一种巧妙方法。
Basically, if the vault senses it's being tampered with, a spring-loaded mechanism fires like a mousetrap, snapping this metal block into place, that physically makes it so the door can't open, even if you have the combination.
基本上，如果金库感觉到它正在被篡改，弹簧加载的机制会像捕鼠器一样触发，将这个金属块咔哒一声锁到位，这在物理上使得门无法打开，即使你有密码。
And when it fires, it goes, bang! It shoots over, and you cannot turn the handle. And I was really nervous about the mousetrap relocker in this particular door.
当它触发时，它会发出砰的一声！它飞过去，你无法转动把手。我对这个特定门上的捕鼠器重锁装置感到非常紧张。
If you're a Prince fan, you maybe know the story of this vault and how it all turned out. But Dave back then, of course, had no idea how it would go. The night before, he was anxious. He reviewed his plans, made sure he had all his tools together.
如果你是王子的粉丝，你可能知道这个金库的故事以及结果如何。但当时的戴夫，当然，不知道会怎样。前一天晚上，他很焦虑。他回顾了他的计划，确保他的工具都准备好了。
On Sunday morning, he flew down to Minneapolis, his gear in a couple of suitcases. There's something intimate opening the safe of someone who has died, an intrusion into the sacred, like you're entering a place you're not supposed to be. In addition to valuables, money, jewelry, once a million baseball card, people keep secrets in safes-- photos of people they aren't married to, letters.
周日早上，他飞往明尼阿波利斯，他的装备装在几个行李箱里。打开一个去世的人的保险箱有一种亲密感，是对神圣的侵犯，就像你进入了一个你不应该进入的地方。除了贵重物品、钱、珠宝，曾经有一百万张棒球卡，人们把秘密存在保险箱里——没结婚的人的照片，信件。
Dave got picked up at the airport and taken to Paisley Park, Prince's home, an estate, really. There were scores of balloons and notes attached to the fence around the property, a wall of purple. The guard waved them through the gate. They parked, and entered this big magnificent building with a huge atrium, large pictures of Prince on the wall, two purple couches, sunlight coming down from above. The vault was on the floor below.
戴夫在机场被接到 Paisley Park，王子的家，其实是个庄园。房产周围的围栏上挂着无数气球和纸条，一片紫色的墙。保安挥手让他们通过大门。他们停车，进入这栋宏伟的大楼，有一个巨大的中庭，墙上挂着王子的巨大图片，两个紫色沙发，阳光从上面射下来。金库在下一层。
Well, we couldn't take the elevator, because it was still walled off, because that's where they had found him. So we had to take the stairs down to the lower level. And the archivist from New York who was there-- just a sweet man-- he led the way down the stairs.
嗯，我们不能坐电梯，因为它仍然被封锁着，因为那是他们发现他的地方。所以我们不得不走楼梯下到下层。而那个在那里的来自纽约的档案管理员——真是个甜美的人——他带路走下楼梯。
Dave says, even after years of doing this, his hands shake sometimes with nerves. He prefers it when he's alone with the vault. But when he goes into the room, there are over a dozen people there. And weirdly, someone has covered everything in plastic-- the art on the walls, all the stuff in the room-- in case, you know, he has to use explosives, which Dave politely explains is not how he works.
戴夫说，即使在做了多年之后，他的手有时还是会紧张地颤抖。他喜欢独自面对金库的时候。但当他进入房间时，有十几个人在那里。奇怪的是，有人用塑料覆盖了一切——墙上的艺术品，房间里的所有东西——以防，你知道，他必须使用炸药，戴夫礼貌地解释这不是他的工作方式。
Dave starts to examine the vault, very aware of all the eyes on him. The door looks like something out of James Bond-- shiny, stainless steel, with black dials. He gives them a spin and notes that they are what in the business are called manipulation-resistant, meaning you can't figure out the combo by feeling how the dial turns.
戴夫开始检查金库，非常意识到所有人的目光都在他身上。门看起来像邦德电影里的东西——闪亮的，不锈钢，有黑色拨盘。他给它们旋转了一下，注意到它们是行话中所谓的抗操纵，意味着你不能通过感觉拨盘转动的方式找出组合密码。
The next thing he does is try some default combinations. Sometimes if a safe has been opened for maintenance, they'll reset it to something simple. And sometimes, the owner doesn't bother to change it. Worth trying.
他做的下一件事是尝试一些默认组合。有时如果一个保险箱因为维护被打开，他们会把它重置为简单的东西。有时，主人懒得换。值得一试。
I tried 50-25-50. It didn't work. I tried 25-50-25. It didn't work, et cetera, et cetera.
我试了50-25-50。不行。我试了25-50-25。不行，等等等等。
A kind of amazing aside here-- Dave says banks often have several of their combo numbers on their vaults set to end in 5 or 0, just because they're easier to dial. That's why the big hash marks are on the dials. But if you're thinking of trying to break into a bank vault, you should know a few things, he says.
这里有个惊人的旁白——戴夫说银行通常把金库密码的最后几个数字设为5或0，只是因为它们更容易拨。这就是拨盘上有大刻度的原因。但如果你在考虑尝试闯入银行金库，你应该知道几件事，他说。
One, there are still tons of possible combinations. Two, bank vaults have a time lock, so they can't be opened after hours. Three, even if you did get in, you'd find the money isn't out in the open. It's inside another safe inside the vault. By that time, the police would be there. Don't try it, he says.
第一，仍有无数可能的组合。第二，银行金库有定时锁，所以它们在下班后不能打开。第三，即使你进去了，你会发现钱并没有放在外面。它在金库里面的另一个保险箱里。那时候，警察就到了。别试了，他说。
Anyway, back to Paisley Park and Prince's vault. Dave turns to the thing he's known he was probably going to have to do from the start-- a technique called microdrilling. He's going to try to drill a small hole through this giant, thick door in just the right spot, so he can look in through that hole and see the combination lock from the inside.
总之，回到 Paisley Park 和王子的金库。戴夫转向他从一开始就知道很可能要做的事情——一种叫显微钻孔的技术。他要尝试钻一个小孔通过这扇巨大的、厚厚的门，在正确的位置，这样他就可以通过那个孔看向内部，看到里面的组合锁。
If he can see the lock tumblers from the inside, he should be able to figure out what combination the vault is set to, and open the door. How do you look in such a small hole? A doctor's endoscope, the thing used for colonoscopies and other procedures. Think very small periscope. Dave always has one with him.
如果他能从内部看到锁簧，他应该能算出金库设置的是什么密码，并打开门。你怎么看那么小的孔？医生用的内窥镜，用于结肠镜检查和其他手术的东西。想想极小的潜望镜。戴夫总是随身带着一个。
But for this to work, he has to drill in just the right place. Only a small number of people know the spot. And Dave is one of the people who has worked out the best way to do this for lots of vaults. He has the coordinates for drill spots for scores of safes and vaults on a laptop.
但要做到这一点，他必须在正确的地方钻孔。只有少数人知道那个点。而戴夫是那些为许多保险箱和金库找到最好钻孔方法的人之一。他的笔记本电脑里有几十个保险箱和金库的钻孔坐标。
And how big is this spot?
那个点有多大？
Oh, it's literally about the size of a frozen pea. It's tiny. And it's a long ways from you. It's deep in the door. There's always a certain amount of trepidation, because if your drill bit veers off at all in any direction other than exactly where you need it to go, you miss.
哦，字面意思上大约是一个冷冻豌豆的大小。很小。离你很远。它在门里很深的地方。总会有一种忐忑感，因为如果你的钻头偏离了你需要它走的任何方向，你就错过了。
And if you miss, the manufacturer has put the mousetrap relocker right there at this magic spot. If it heats up from too much drilling, it'll blow. Dave measures out the right spot on the front of the vault door, puts a dot there with a black Sharpie, checks the position three times, and starts to drill. The drill goes through the outer steel layer, then into some very hard concrete. And then--
如果你错过了，制造商正好在那个神奇的点放了捕鼠器重锁装置。如果它因为钻孔太热而升温，它就会爆炸。戴夫测量了保险箱门前侧的正确位置，用黑色记号笔点了一个点，检查了三次位置，开始钻孔。钻头穿过外层钢层，然后进入一些非常坚硬的混凝土。然后——
We're drilling away, and then all of a sudden, the sound of the drill motor increases. Zzzzzzzzzz! It's not cutting.
我们钻着钻着，然后突然，钻头电机的声音变大了。兹兹兹兹！它钻不动了。
Dave looks through the hole and can see why. They've hit the hard plate. Vaultmakers give their hard plates all kinds of names. There's one called Impervium.
戴夫通过那个孔看向内部，可以看到原因。他们撞上了硬板。金库制造者给他们的硬板起了各种名字。有一种叫 Impervium。
The one on Prince's vault, it's the first time he's seen it on this vault. It's called Relsom, which is the vault company's name, Mosler, spelled backwards. He wonders if Prince asked for an upgrade.
王子金库上的那个，是他第一次在这个金库上看到它。它叫 Relsom，也就是那个金库公司的名字，Mosler，倒着拼。他想王子是否要求升级了。
Dave reaches into his bag and takes out another drill bit, this one with a diamond tip. He lowers the drill speed. He has to go slow. If he doesn't, the metal in the door will heat up, and the relocker will fire.
戴夫伸手进他的包里取出另一个钻头，这个是钻石头的。他降低钻头速度。他必须慢点。如果不慢，门里的金属会变热，重锁装置就会触发。
10 minutes pass, 20, 30, an hour. He's made less than half an inch of progress. Everyone's standing around watching, Dave nervous. And then, the drill sound changes. He's through. His only question-- did the relocker fire while he was drilling, or did he slip past it?
10分钟过去，20，30，一个小时。他只钻进去不到半英寸。每个人都站在周围看着，戴夫很紧张。然后，钻头声音变了。他穿过去了。他唯一的问题——在他钻孔时重锁装置触发了吗，还是他溜过去了？
Once the hole was in, I grabbed an endoscope, and you're sweating bullets at that point.
一旦孔钻好，我抓起内窥镜，那时你紧张得直冒冷汗。
Dave threads it through this tiny, long hole in the big door.
戴夫把它穿过大门上那个细长的小孔。
I could see that we'd just skimmed over the top of it, and didn't even graze it, but we were very close to it. The scope goes on inside the lock, where the tumblers are. I could see the-- each of the four little tumblers, they looked like little grindstones, turning this way and that. It was a beautiful sight to see.
我能看出我们刚好从它上方擦过，甚至没碰到它，但我们离它非常近。内窥镜进入锁内，锁簧所在的地方。我能看到——四个小锁簧中的每一个，它们看起来像小磨石，转来转去。那是美丽的景象。
Dave turns the combo dials on the front of the safe until he can see everything is aligned on the inside. That should do it. It occurs to him that Prince might have been the last person to open the vault. He turns the big wheel and pulls. The giant door swings slowly open.
戴夫转动保险箱前面的密码盘，直到他能看到里面的一切都对齐了。这就成了。他想到王子可能是最后一个打开金库的人。他转动那个大转轮，用力一拉。巨大的门慢慢打开了。
What was the reaction in the room?
房间里是什么反应？
Applause. Everybody-- everybody clapped. I was a little embarrassed. When the door came open, the archivist looked inside before I did. I've just been trained, through decades of doing this, not to look.
掌声。每个人——每个人都鼓掌了。我有点尴尬。当门打开时，档案管理员在我之前看了看里面。我经过几十年的训练，已经养成了不看的习惯。
Dave heard someone gasp.
戴夫听到有人倒吸一口气。
And I looked inside and realized why. Very large vault-- I don't know the exact dimension, but approximately 20 feet by 40 feet. Now, by bank standards, that is on the large side. And yet, there was hardly any room in the vault, because it was just jam-packed with these industrial shelving units, and every one of them was packed bottom to top with tapes.
我看向里面，意识到原因。非常大的金库——我不知道确切尺寸，但大约20英尺乘40英尺。现在，按银行标准，那是大的一侧。然而，金库里几乎没有空间，因为它塞满了这些工业货架单元，每一个都从底到顶塞满了磁带。
The vault was filled with music, thousands of recordings, most of it never released. One small detail I hadn't heard before-- it seemed, kind of, sweet. Dave has a picture of this.
金库里塞满了音乐，成千上万的录音，大部分从未发行过。我之前没听过的一个小细节——看起来，有点甜美。戴夫有这个的照片。
There was a piece of paper hanging in the vault by a very old computer. It apparently functioned as a database, because the paper had instructions. "Introducing Mr. Vault Guy. That's right. No more messy papercuts. To use Mr. Vault Guy, follow these simple instructions.
金库里挂着一张纸，在一台非常旧的电脑旁边。它显然是作为数据库运行的，因为纸上有指令。“介绍一下伏特先生。没错。不再有肮脏的纸张。使用伏特先生，请遵循这些简单指令。
One, choose The Vault. Enter. Two, choose Search, slash Update, Enter twice." Like I said, it was an old computer. "Press F10, and voila. Continue pressing F10, and all tapes under these categories will appear."
第一，选择金库。输入。第二，选择搜索，斜杠更新，输入两次。”就像我说的，那是一台旧电脑。“按 F10，然后瞧。继续按 F10，这些类别下的所有磁带就会出现。”
And at the end, it read, "dig it? Dig it. Any questions? Ask Chuck." Dave looked around the vault. Prince was famously prolific, constantly making and recording things.
在最后，写着，“挖出来了吗？挖出来。有问题吗？问查克。”戴夫环顾金库。王子以多产著称，不断地制作和录音。
The two of them were about the same age. Prince was 57 when he died. Dave was 59.
他们俩年纪差不多。王子去世时57岁。戴夫59岁。
Well, it's just sad to be cut down relatively young, still full of things to offer the world. It's super sad.
嗯，被相对年轻地终结，还有很多东西要提供给世界，这只是令人难过。这超级令人难过。
Yeah, it was like you were there in the presence of all the stuff he hadn't finished, you know.
是的，就像你置身于所有他没完成的东西之中，你知道。
Right.
没错。
They've started to release some of that stuff from inside the vault. The first recording was called "Piano and a Microphone." It was Prince, just playing a piano and singing.
他们开始发行一些金库里的东西了。第一张录音叫“钢琴与麦克风”。那是王子，只是弹着钢琴唱歌。
I wanted to play you one of the songs. But you know what's even more difficult than opening up a bank vault? Licensing a Prince song for use on the radio. Prince, throughout his life, was famous for wanting to control the music he made. There's a reason he kept it in a vault.
我想给你听其中一首歌。但你知道比打开银行金库更困难的是什么吗？授权在广播中使用王子的歌。王子，在他的一生中，以想要控制他制作的音乐而闻名。他把它存在金库里是有原因的。
When you hear one of these recordings from the vault, is there any part of you that feels like, I helped make that happen, in some small way?
当你听到其中一些金库里的录音时，你有没有觉得，我以某种微小的方式帮助实现了它？
No, not at all.
没有，一点也不。
There are all kinds of people who are excellent in what they do. They are the types of people who can write so many songs, they fill a vault. There's a quieter kind also. The kind who can get those songs out so smoothly, you don't know how hard it was.
有各种各样的人在他们做的事情上非常出色。他们是那种能写出那么多歌、填满一个金库的人。也有一种更安静的。那种能把那些歌顺滑地取出来，你甚至不知道这有多难的人。
David Kestenbaum is our senior editor. Dave McOmie has written a memoir. It's called Safecracker, A Chronicle of the Coolest Job in the World.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆是我们的资深编辑。戴夫·麦科米写了一本回忆录。叫《保险箱专家，世界上最酷工作的编年史》。
[MUSIC - "ARE YOU GOING MY WAY" BY THE ESSEX]
[音乐 - 埃塞克斯乐队的“ARE YOU GOING MY WAY”]
Our program was produced today by Bim Adewunmi. The people who put together today's program include Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Andrea Lopez Cruzado, Aviva DeKornfeld, Damien Graef, Chana Jaffe-Walt, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Alix Spiegel, Jessica Suriano, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, Chloee Weiner, and Diane Wu.
我们今天的节目是由比姆·阿德温米制作的。组建今天节目的人员包括达纳·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、安德烈亚·洛佩兹·克鲁扎多、阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、达米安·格拉夫、查纳·贾菲-沃尔特、莉娜·米西齐斯、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、杰西卡·苏里亚诺、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克、克洛伊·韦纳和黛安·吴。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman, our senior editor is David Kestenbaum, our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Scotty Anderson, Matt Dittman, Charlie Vela, Josiah Kosier, Maureen Meyer, Rafael Garcia, Rochelle Garza, Kerry Glencorse, Steve Gough, and Chris Crawford. The voice actors for the smuggler story, Act 1, in order of appearance-- Isaiah Zavala, Ezekiel Pacheco, Gilberto Ortiz, and Elijah Rodriguez.
我们的主编是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼，资深编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆，执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里。今天特别感谢斯科蒂·安德森、马特·迪特曼、查理·维拉、乔赛亚·科西尔、莫琳·迈耶、拉斐尔·加西亚、罗谢尔·加尔萨、克里·格伦科斯、史蒂夫·高夫和克里斯·克劳福德。走私犯故事（第一幕）的配音演员，按出场顺序——以赛亚·萨瓦拉、以西结·帕切科、吉尔伯托·奥尔蒂斯和以利亚·罗德里格斯。
Our website-- ThisAmericanLife.org, This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr Torey Malatia.
我们的网站——ThisAmericanLife.org，《美国生活》由 PRX（公共无线电交换）发送给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。
You know, I was in a long line at the coffee shop this week. And I got to the front, I was about to order, Torey walks in, cuts the line, comes right up to me. I told him, "Torey, you can't jump in front of all these people!"
你知道，这周我在咖啡店排长队。我到了前面，正要点餐，托里走进来，插队，径直走到我面前。我告诉他，“托里，你不能排在所有人前面！”
He wouldn't listen. Put his hands over his ears says to me--
他不听。捂住耳朵对我说——
"Zzzzzzzzzz! It's not cutting."
“兹兹兹兹！它钻不动了。”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《美国生活》的故事回来。